what if one Zone on your sprinkler
system isn't coming on or isn't shutting
off but the rest of your system's
working okay could be your valve could
be your controller or it could be your
wiring how do you tell which today we're
going to help you troubleshoot your
malfunctioning Zone Dwayne Smith here
your irrigation product specialist let's
get to it
[Music]
in order to properly troubleshoot some
of the electrical components you will
either need a solenoid activator
chatterer or you could use a Multimeter
also called a volt meter for this video
we will be using the Pro 50 activator
chatter by Armada an activator is a
tester that's specifically designed for
irrigation and it makes this task much
simpler we have an almost identical
video to this one where we go through
the same process using a volt meter if
you don't have access to an activator
cheddar go and check out the other video
that uses the multimeter so let's start
troubleshooting problem one a zone won't
stop running even when the controller is
set to stop watering if the watering is
definitely off at the controller then
this kind of issue is something that
would probably not be caused by a faulty
controller it's nearly certain that's a
valve issue let's talk about what that
looks like if your Zone should not be on
but the sprinklers in that zone are on
or they're sort of on maybe they've got
water dribbling from the top of several
heads or if you few heads are popping up
and not just for a few minutes after the
Zone shuts off it's happening
continuously then the valve for that
zone is not closing all the way so in
that case you're going to have to find
and replace the bow problem two one zone
isn't coming on all the way that may
look like several heads not popping up
within the Zone perhaps none of them are
but there's water seeping from the top
of some of the heads then most likely
your valve isn't opening all the way if
that's the case you're going to need to
find and replace that valve although
another possibility is that you've got a
broken pipe you'll almost certainly have
a wet mushy spot in the yard and maybe
even a puddle you'll need to turn off
the water at the back flow or water
meter and then repair that brake problem
three one zone won't come on at all this
is the most difficult problem to
diagnose I have seen one case where the
customer's module was not properly
seated and there was an error code on
the control roller if you have a modular
controller make sure that the module is
inserted properly and locked into place
also make sure it's not a programming
error go through the program to
determine that the zone is scheduled to
run and for how long you can run a
manual cycle and Skip ahead to that zone
most controllers will have some sort of
indicator on the screen to show that The
Zone should be on
if the controller is showing that the
Zone should be running but the
sprinklers in that zone are not coming
on at all this could be a problem with
the controller itself the wiring between
the controller and the valve or the
solenoid on the valve we'll need to do
some electrical troubleshooting
let's talk briefly about what happens
when a controller activates a valve to
activate a Zone the controller sends 24
volts of electricity through a lead wire
to the solenoid on the valve the
solenoid is connected to both the lead
wire and to a common wire the common
wire is also connected to all the valves
in your system and heads back to the
controller that completes the circuit
when the solenoid is activated it opens
up the valve sending water to the
sprinklers so let's check to see if the
controller is working properly grab your
Pro 50 hit the power button you should
see this screen this is a 24 volt system
this is only going to work on a regular
controller not a battery operated one
I'm going to hit the arrow key to the
right to indicate 24 volts now I've got
this screen I'm testing for vac so I hit
the F3 key under vac I'm going to put
one clip on the common and one on the
Zone which I'm testing start a manual
cycle for that zone you're testing
and I should see around 24 volts in this
case it's a little over It's Not Unusual
there will be some voltage loss in the
wiring depending on how long your wiring
is to the valve and the gauge of the
wire so a little extra juice here at the
terminals not a bad thing at all this
terminal is definitely working if the
terminal is not working that means your
controller is malfunctioning or if you
have a modular controller it could just
be that the module is bad you could try
replacing that module if you have
another terminal that's not being used
you could switch the wire from the
non-working Zone to the available
terminal and reprogram the controller to
run that zone instead even if you can
make that work you will still probably
have to replace the controller
eventually because it's on its way out
but this will buy you some time maybe
even a few seasons if you don't have
another terminal available and assuming
it's not a module issue you're going to
need a new controller it's a great time
to upgrade if you've got a base model
you might want to check out a smart
controller that can change its
programming based on local weather
stations and you can program it with
your smartphone so check out the choices
on sprinklerwarehouse.com assuming that
your terminal is working perfectly your
problem is either the solenoid on your
valve or the wiring to test the wiring
and the solenoid wheel will be testing
resistance push the arrow key on the Pro
50 until you get to this screen press
the F2 key underneath the omega symbol
leave the clips on the terminals the
readings will jump around a little bit
and then settle I've got 42 ohms that's
good a 24 volt system like this is going
to be between 20 and 60 ohms if you've
got a battery operated system that
you're testing that would mean that the
solenoid on your valve is DC latching
you'll see around 5 to 10 ohms
resistance ratings for the valve you
have are available on the manufacturer's
website if the screen is showing this
three line lines you've got a break in
the wiring or a bad solenoid if you've
got a short in the system you'll see
something like this less than 5 ohms it
may even read zero ohms it means that
you've got wires touching somewhere that
shouldn't be touching so let's assume
that you've got a bad report here the
Pro 50 has indicated either a break in a
circuit or a short then we'll need to
move out to the valve to continue
troubleshooting out here at the valve
disconnect the wires from the solenoid
from the wiring coming from the
controller we're going to test the
solenoid a few different ways you don't
need to do all of this just pick one
the most direct way is to turn on the
solenoid put the clips on the solenoid
wires
press F3 for 24 volt system and F1 if
you've got a battery operated system
with DC latching solenoids from this
screen press F1
The Zone should come on let it run for
just a few seconds
and F3 to turn it off one note here if
you have a master valve on your system
the water is not going to come on unless
the controller is currently running the
Zone you're testing the master valve
proceeds all the valves in your system
and nothing can run without it on it
another option is to chatter the
solenoid now you don't want to chatter
the solenoid with the water on the water
to your system should be turned off at
the backflow or at the water main if
you're chattering press the F2 button to
chatter it sounds like this
foreign
and yet another test you can do would be
to test the resistance just like we did
at the controller I'm going to press the
right arrow button and then press f2
underneath the omega symbol because this
is a 24 vac system I'm looking for
something between 20 and 60 ohms 43 ohms
that's good less than 5 ohms or if you
get like the three lines like this then
the solenoid is Bad If This Were DC
latching solenoid 5 to 10 ohms would
indicate a good solenoid so if you've
got a bad solenoid you need to replace
either the solenoid or the entire valve
usually the price difference between a
replacement solenoid and the entire
valve is usually just a couple of bucks
I would go ahead and buy a new valve if
I were you if you're just replacing the
solenoid you'll need to find out the
correct one for your model of valve the
valve solenoids are not generic there's
a specific one you need if you're
replacing the entire valve any valve
that's the same type and size will do
now when I say type I mean inline
anti-siphon angle this is an inline one
and it's a one inch valve so you can
replace it with any one inch valve
that's in line you don't have to match
modeler brand any brand works with any
controller Etc you do need to buy a DC
latching solenoid version if your system
is battery powered system and finally
Let's test the wiring connect the clips
to the wires coming from the controller
start the Zone you're testing
set your Pro 50 to test for vac like we
did earlier
and we're looking for around 24 vac once
again if you get three lines you've got
broken wiring if you get something
really low it could be a short check
your Connections in the valve box
hopefully that's the problem try making
fresh connections and always use
waterproof wire connectors if that
doesn't fix it you may need to run new
wire which is a real pain if you happen
to have multi-strand wire coming into
the valve and one of the strands in the
multi-strand is not being used and
congratulations you've just hit the
jackpot somebody's already run your new
wire for you just swap to an unused wire
and swap the wire back at the controller
if there is another valve nearby an
option is to use a doubler the doubler
operates two valves using only one lead
wire that could potentially save you a
lot of work and headaches so check out
that option hope this helps questions
chat with one of our incredible customer
service agents on sprinklerwarehouse.com
they really do know their stuff and
they'll get you squared away get
everything you need for that next
landscape project from sprinkler
Warehouse a proud member of the Heritage
Landscape Supply Group your success is
our heritage sprinkler Warehouse
America's most shop sprinkler store
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
helpful tips tutorials and general
sprinkler instruction
foreign